do you need to make a new car key for
your toyota rav4 or for a lot of other
toyota vehicles i'm going to show you
how my company tom's key company can
help you make a new key
and remote for your toyota rav4 as well
as many other vehicles it's really easy
to do and it'll save you a bunch of
money over the cost of the dealership
let me show you how it's done okay so
here's my working key it's the one with
the tile key finder on it in case i lose
it
[Music]
you can see it's locking and unlocking
the doors
and here's the new one
see it doesn't work you're going to need
a master key that's really easy to find
out just look at the red blinking light
slide working key in watch the light
if
stops blinking right away like that it's
a master key if it turns on solid beds
for two seconds have a valet key
and you need to get a master key before
we can help you make another one now the
new one this doesn't even have to be cut
notice the blinking red light as we
slide it in
it'll keep blinking because this chip
the chip inside here has not been
programmed to start the vehicle you'll
know you're successful when that red
light turns off when your order arrives
inside the box you'll find tom's car key
programmer model tsl1 along with the
cable we're going to connect the cable
down near the brake and gas pedal and
then we're going to start by programming
the remote simply make sure the switch
is pushed to remote i'm going to take my
working key
put it in the ignition turn it two
clicks to the on position
[Music]
and then i'm going to plug in
the programmer
with it on the remote setting
[Music]
we'll hear the programmers start beeping
is it
door
with the door open when it changes beat
patterns push lock and unlock for one
second and then lock
and you hit the car
this remote is now programmed
it's super easy to check we're going to
unplug the programmer
after taking the working key out of the
ignition we'll check our new one
[Music]
lock
unlock here's the old one
[Music]
this remote is now programmed we now
need to turn to programming the chip
portion of the key to program the key
chip we need to change the slider to the
key position like that
take our working key
and put it in the ignition and turn it
two clicks to the on position
we're going to be watching the red light
up here
so take the programmer plug it in
it's going to start beeping
[Music]
as it starts peeping watch for the red
light to turn on solid red
okay there it is turned on solid red
that means
take out the working key we're gonna set
that aside put the new key
in and now it's going to start blinking
it'll blink at a steady one blink on one
blink off about one second on one second
off for 60 seconds
so now we just need to wait
at the end of 60 seconds
the blinking red light will turn off all
right we're almost at 60 seconds so this
red light is going to turn off there
it's turned off this key is now
programmed
you can unplug the programmer and notice
the blinking light
it's blinking no keys in the ignition
put a programmed key in now
and it turns right off don't forget to
cut the emergency keyblade to avoid the
hassle of finding a car dealership or
locksmith you can order our optional key
by photo key cutting service you simply
upload three photos after placing your
order
and with the wonders of technology your
key will arrive cut ready to fit your
vehicle
and then you simply return tom's car key
programmer to get your deposit refunded
we do charge a deposit fee to make sure
these come back
after someone rents its program
and that's it that's how easy it is to
program
new car key and remote with tom's key
company visit tomsky.com
[Music]
to order yours today
also please leave comments like the
video and subscribe that really does
help youtube if you're commenting and
liking the video so that other people
can find just how easy it is to program
a new car key and remote with tom's key
company
thanks for watching have a great day